she's safe she's on a plane she's on her
way home after months of being unjustly
detained in Russia held under
ontolerable circumstances Brittany will
soon be back in the arms of her loved
ones and uh and she should have been
there all along
this is a day we've worked toward for a
long time we never stopped pushing for
her release it took painstaking and
intense negotiations and I want to thank
all the hard-working public servants
across my Administration who work
tirelessly to secure her release
I also want to thank the UAE for helping
us facilitate Brittany's return because
that's where she landed
these past few months have been hell for
Brittany and for Charlene and uh and her
entire family and all her teammates back
home people all across the country have
learned about Britney's story advocate
of her release stood with her through
throughout this terrible ordeal and I
know that support meant a lot to her
family I'm glad to be able to say that
Britney's in good spirits
she she's relieved to finally be heading
home and the fact remains that she's
lost months of her life experienced the
needless trauma and she deserves space
privacy and time with her loved ones to
recover and heal from her time being
wrongfully detained
Brittany is uh is an incomparable
athlete a two-time Olympic gold medalist
for Team USA she endured mistreatment
and I showed at a show trial in Russia
with characteristic grit and incredible
dignity
she represents the best America
best about America it is across the
board everything about her
she wrote to me back in July
she didn't ask for special treatment
even though we've been working on a
release from the day one she requested a
simple quote please don't forget about
me and the other American detainees
please do all you can to bring us home
we never forgot about Brittany we've not
forgotten about Paul Whalen who's been
unjustly detained in Russia for years
this was not a choice of which American
to bring home we brought home Trevor
Reed when we had a chance earlier this
year
sadly for totally illegitimate reasons
Russia is treating Paul's case
differently than Britney's and while we
have not yet succeeded in securing
Paul's release we are not giving up we
will never give up we remain in close
touch with Paul's family the wheel and
family and my thoughts and prayers are
with him today they have to have such
mixed emotions today
and we'll keep negotiating in good faith
for Paul's release I guarantee that I
say that to the family I guarantee you
I urge Russia to do the same to ensure
that Paul's health and you and your main
treatment on uh maintained until we are
able to bring him home I don't want any
American to sit wrongfully detained and
one extra day if we can bring that
person home my Administration has now
brought home dozens of Americans who are
wrongfully detained are held hostages
abroad many of whom had been held since
before I took office and today we also
remember the other Americans that are
being held hostage and wrongfully
detained in Russia or anywhere else in
the world
reuniting this Americans with their
loved ones remains a priority a priority
for my administration every person in my
Administration involved in this we're
going to continue to work to bring home
every American who continues to endure
such an injustice